the big one yes so c little c the speed
of light uh probably one of the most
famous uh symbols used in the whole of
physics certainly appears in the most
famous equation there is in the whole of
physics e equals m c squared the c in
there is the speed of light um and it's
so it really is one of the most
fundamental consonants in the whole of
physics
c small c means the speed of light
that's what
three times ten to the eighth meters per
second so 300 million meters per second
so it's fast but not infinitely fast so
it really is i mean it's the ultimate
constant in physics in the sense that it
really is the same whoever measures it
that's what lies at the heart of special
relativity this idea that the universe
is a relative sort of place is that one
of the
the precepts of special relativity is
that the laws of physics are the same
whatever reference frame you're in so if
you're stationary if you're moving you
should see the same laws of physics why
is the speed of light c
why is it set to be c or why is it
called c
that i don't know i don't know why it's
i really don't know why it's we've how
that constant has been defined as as
being called say i'd be interested to
know if mike knows
maybe because it's thought to be a
fundamental constant c for constant but
i i don't really know
people are kind of used to the idea that
speeds add so that for example if you
see an aircraft taking off from an
aircraft carrier uh if you want to know
how fast the aircraft's actually going
you have to add how fast the aircraft is
moving relative to the aircraft carrier
to how fast the aircraft carrier was
moving forward so the total speed of the
plane is the sum of the two and people
are very used to that kind of idea and
in fact it's the calculation you use
every time you cross the road to
calculate how fast the car's coming
towards you and so on you're measuring
relative speeds of things but the weird
thing about light is because the speed
of light is always the same it doesn't
add in that way so if you're piling
along in a train and you shine a
flashlight from the train and you
measure the speed the light comes out of
the flashlight at it comes out at
exactly the same speed as if you weren't
in the train in the first place so
speeds don't add that the speed of light
whoever measures it however you produce
the light always comes out to the same
value c
that's not quite true that's the speed
of light in a vacuum there are ways to
actually get light to slow down so there
are certainly if you if light travels
through air for example it travels a
little more slowly it can never go
faster than the speed it goes in the
vacuum but you can make it slow down and
people do some really sophisticated
experiments in the laboratory to
actually slow light down to a snail's
place by messing around with what's
known as the refractive index of the
material messing around with the
properties of the material it's
propagating through so you can make it
slow down you can never exceed the the
speed that it goes in the vacuum so c is
in that sense a sort of cosmic speed
limit it's the fastest speed there is do
that have much to do with your work and
speciality is c very important to you
well um
if for my sort of
evening and weekend
thinking about physics yes because i
like to read books about cosmology and
think about things like that
most of the experiments we do in this
lab we're looking at electrons moving in
semiconductors which are moving at
speeds well below the speed of light
typically about 100th the speed of light
how do we measure the speed of light
these days it's a quite a difficult
thing to measure for the longest time uh
the experiments were kind of quite crude
and the constraint we had on the speed
of light were quite limited some of the
best measurements we have nowadays are
actually by uh doing radar echoes of
things you can actually just bounce a
radar beam of things because it's called
the speed of light but of course all
electromagnetic waves travel at the same
speed so if it's a radio wave an x-ray
an optical light it all travels at the
same speed so by bouncing radio waves of
things we can actually measure the speed
pretty accurately so good thing to
balance it off is another planet because
they were kind of a long way away so
because speed the light travels
extremely fast it's three three times
ten to the eight meters per second
that's 300 million meters every second
light travels at so obviously you can't
just sit there with a stopwatch and try
and measure the speed of light that way
because it just goes too fast
unless you can find something that's a
long way away so bouncing light off the
moon of other planets by by using strong
radar signals is a very good way of
actually measuring how fast that light's
going and do you know exactly what it is
i can't tell you exactly no because it's
it's defined an awful lot of decimal
places and one of the nice things about
astronomy is we very really need to know
things very accurately and so as i say
for an astronomer's purposes it's 300
million meters per second but actually
it's not exactly 300 million meters per
second
yes it's something like 2.999
something eight times three times ten to
the eight meters per second but i can't
remember that exactly but three point
zero zero is a very good three point
zero zero times ten to eight meters per
second is a very good approximation oh
yeah three by ten to the image was
second
i actually yes i cheat i have a pocket
calculator that's got all these physical
constants built into it so i just press
the little button mark c and i get it to
come up on the display without having to
know the value
you